diane swonk list is long later
in that they live here knows about it in
full sun and who repeated this slump
would like artnîm differed typhoid is
a free man
tolerances was democratic
disease drugs conditions
live there black and results  ingrid
hayes colakoglu giovanni tepa on the
deputies ms dati in the siren
terrorism
we want to find our
national borders we do not
trust the borders of europe which are
a real sieve
we do ninja match tsonga brings closer to
radicalization ground and line  the prison
another place of radicalization on which
we have turned a blind eye for too long
those who perpetrated and formed the
attacks in pabbi are exactly the
same who forces the unfortunates of his
planet to fruit proud canaries count
in libya a criticism either the
plaintiff francesas me  para los
tiempos 2011 de massilia aids which the
threat is global
mustang made
the v  ideos of europe by
the fact that by its existence the
film has generated an agreement between three
countries france germany and turkey
and is there ridha better sharing of
multinationals that operate in europe eu
by counting the workforce  606
department stores in catillon chaos their
group or boss of ouch seconds from the buzzer
or microsoft has lower china if you
want us to create pressure
give us access to the documents and
frankly the way in which you
gave us access to them and I  finds unworthy
of a democracy
we wanted this budget to be at the
service of growth at the service
of employment and that it respond to the challenges of
migration and the reception of refugees,
but our budget leaves us helpless as
soon as a  major crisis and
well of a rate at 10 years came back dia
before the assault resin or nalaga its
Italian a hard blow sata strike
indeed attacks the head to the rabbinate
allaire hardcore of various origins and
rigorous by giving 1  0
ricordeau of the fight against
school violence are illegal this
is the time to defend is this not
there also these times covered watts so
that the army reduces to the point of an
experience of 4 to 6 years
demos is the  communications summit
and the diario how i have left that
for the subway is safe let die his
ace assassination